wilken weil große alten schule und hier
ist wieder gastgeber war es allerdings
wieder einmal waren und bekam zu einer
neuen folge
ich rette ein video und heute ist mein
eigenes video denn nach über bereits
sich folgend sind es 30 seit über 30
folgen nach 30 bäumen ist mir ein fehler
passiert und so habe ich die falschen
cache von damon gemacht weiß ehrlich
gesagt nicht wie dieser fehler passieren
konnte denn ich habe diese folgen so
gründlich durchgeschaut und haben nicht
diesen richtigen pancake gefunden und
dann hat sich das video hochgeladen habe
bestand die hälfte der kommentare
eigentlich daraus mir zu sagen das ist
die falsche pancakes sagt und dann
dachte ich mir wetten wir sind selbst
der perfekteste mensch der welt machen
fehler
graf eine perfekte moment als grundlage
braucht man natürlich zuerst wieder dem
campact eib und dafür brauchen eine
schüssel und für die leute die natürlich
wieder ganz aufmerksam zugeschaut haben
das oberteil und die habe ich ja aus wie
die weibliche version von damon geil wir
brauchen natürlich mehl zucker 2 1
naja backpulver darauf kommt noch eine
prise salz und natürlich ein bisschen
fett und nun brauchen wir herzen um
diesen magic spam zu versenden
magische kerzen
helft mir meine fehler werde ich nun
feuer erzeugen und nun wenn ich mit
meiner drachenbauer diese kerze anzünden
warum musste kommen da rechenpower aber
damit die kerzen ihre richtige wirkung
zeigen dass ein bisschen cool aussieht
müssen wir richtig
[Musik]
was macht sie jetzt zaubern wir aus den
zutaten
[Musik]
irgendwas hat mit unserem zauber nicht
funktioniert was mein gott leute das
glaubt ihr mich sie steht es gibt neue
sky angebot zwei monate sky
entertainment ticket für vier euro 99
und wenn man schnell ist dann kann man
noch den restlichen oktober dazu
bekommen das bedeutet für 499 kann man
bis zum ende des jahres teilte themen
ticket angucken und und jetzt kommt auch
wirklich aber das krasseste guy hat
nämlich die neue staffel walking dead
seit dem 18
in der library also ich wusste ja schon
dass ich mit zaubern kann aber das hat
selbst mich jetzt überall schneien ihr
müsst einfach mal vorstellen
ihr könnt es vom blitzkrieg vom
smartphone vom tv ihr könnt es ganz in
der ganzen eu stream
selbst wenn jetzt in urlaub fahren auf
malle und euch das dauert ein bisschen
zu klein ist könnt ihr euch hinsetzen
und entertainment schauen also das recht
ein magisches angebot findet natürlich
wieder alle links unten in der
beschreibung wo ich das gelbe trikot
es gibt auch ihr blog aber genug von den
slightly wir müssen ja hier unsere
pancakes tabaluga seid ihr bereit
dahinter chaman verschwinden und bringe
mia
[Musik]
es hat funktioniert ja und nun geht es
uns beraten
[Musik]
auf ihn wartet ist jahrgang gesehen dass
viele meinen pancakes markt gemacht
haben herausragend sehr gutes passiert
mir hier zusammen stehen habe ich auch
selber gemacht wirklich die vermutung
dass der perfekt nur teil bedeutend
größer als das verkleidet ihr euch
eigentlich ein halloween ich bin mir
noch nicht sicher dieses ja ich habe
auch von box- und halloween verkleidungs
video wieder zu machen die letztes jahr
mit krimineller aber war immer hier die
10 witzigsten halloween kostüme das
video kleiner tipp hier von der punk
queen als speed queen
wenn ihr mal dass so eine gleichmäßige
fläche ist dann müsste die pfanne sehr
lang haben in der hitze damit der teig
zeit hat sich so zu verteidigen
dann erst wird
mix leute leute so muss es aussehen
flotten drei jahren war warschau im iran
und er hat auch diesen perfekten flow
fürs bilderbuch die zutatenliste sehr
kurz als topping eine minimale banking
sind jetzt fertig hacks kartoffelbrei 66
jetzt kommt der beste moment jetzt legen
wir unsere perfekten pancakes perfekt
übereinander so dass für einen perfekten
sturm haben oh mein gott leute sieht aus
als ob die nicht echt werden als ob das
irgendwann china fabrik aus plastik
gemacht hätte weil ich einfach die
perfekte niedrige hitze ist bequem und
ich noch mehr demenz design und diesmal
wirklich wer was gemacht
ja so ganz kompliziert dass man jetzt
wie sollen hier sieben stück jetzt
stellen uns wieder der allerwichtigsten
frage
die haben uns schon gestellt ja ankum
gerettet damon ich hoffe ihr werdet alle
zufrieden und so richtig satisfied dass
ich jetzt richtig gemacht habe lasst uns
probieren ein bisschen sahne beste was
ein bisschen mehr bären
bisschen mehr sonne und ein guter schutz
und der mensch fähig sind gerettet ich
liebe das sie aber immer so mehrere
pancakes übereinander ist und dass am
ende dieses stück kuchen wirkt ich werde
jetzt jede woche bank noch nie so gute
plan klicks gegessen und wir nur ein 1 1
[Musik]
jetzt bekomme ich richtig los so walking
der zu schauen
die neue staffel und mit daems geräte
mit könnt ihr jetzt das gleiche tun für
499 könnt ihr zwei monate lang skye tm
entwickelt ausprobieren alle serien
wieder drauf sind könnt ihr schauen wenn
ihr schnell seid dann könnt ihr noch den
oktober mitnehmen geradelt und somit bis
ende des jahres alle serien reinziehen
the walking dead vier blocks bei uns
natürlich und damit auch keine lange
bindung eingehen sondern könnt es
monatlich kündigen und das finde ich
sehr gut meine damen und herren
bodypacker in guter übergang ein
deswegen sage ich
er tötete koste es ist schön ich hoffe
wir sind es bald keine wir haben
bestehen geblieben
also entweder steht nur werbung oder
nicht so leute und jetzt ohne spaß ich
jetzt wirklich die walking dead gucken
ich bin sehr gespannt wie es weiter geht
und ihr probiert man die gesandten aus
[Musik]